faire preuve d'optimisme à propos des
otages français du liban c'est allé trop
vite en besogne lorsqu'il s'agit de la
vie de quatre hommes détenus pour
certains depuis huit mois maintenant
mais tout de même ce soir pour la
première fois il apparaît que la
négociation s'est vraiment engagé on
commence à savoir ce que veulent les
ravisseurs en échange leurs otages c'est
peu mais c'est déjà un point de repère
bueno alba
alors le malade si monsieur carton si
marcel quart-temps avec le retour du
docteur rade de beyrouth on a bien plus
que des nouvelles rassurantes sur l'état
de santé des otages et si le docteur rad
a pu se dire très optimiste quant à leur
sort c'est vraisemblablement que sa
mission lui semble fructueuse
relayant les démarches des familles ici
les comités kaufmann l'appareil les
émissaires français sont semble-t-il en
mesure d'apporter des éléments de
réponse à trois questions qui sont
exactement les ravisseurs que veulent
t'ils précisément comment résoudre la
faire à la question que veulent les
ravisseurs de réponse possible d'abord
le remboursement de tout ou partie d'un
investissement d'un milliard de dollars
décidée par le shah en 1975 dans le
consortium nucléaire euros d'isf
personne n'écarte pas la possibilité
qu'il s'agisse de l'une des conditions
posées à téhéran pour la libération des
otages
initiatives individuelles dans ce sens
un député français de la majorité
monsieur d'aillet se rendra à téhéran
avec des députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition pour tenter une ébauche de
normalisation des relations franco
iraniennes une autre condition pourrait
être la libération des auteurs iranien
d'un attentat contre l'ancien premier
ministre chapour bakhtiar c'était à de
paris le 18 juillet 1981 ils ont été
condamnés par la justice et sont
toujours détenus en france monsieur
bakhtiar a été sorti indemne de cette
action qui avait provoqué la mort de
deux autres personnes
la négociation semble donc passer par
l'iran à tel point que madame joëlle
kauffmann la femme de l'un des otages
français a écrit personnellement une
lettre à l'imam khomeiny convoqué à
l'ambassade d'iran à paris on lui a fait
savoir que son message avait été bien
reçu et que cette démarche n'était pas
inutile